wenn es euch so geht wie mir dann seid
ihr schon wieder richtig heiß drauf die
ersten aussaten zu machen im Januar muss
man sich da noch ein bisschen zügeln
aber es gibt schon eine ganze Menge an
Gemüse das jetzt schon in die Erde darf
deswegen schnappt euch mal euer Saatgut
und dann bringen wir die allerersten
Samen des Jahres in die Erde und wir
starten mit einer Pflanze die eigentlich
gar kein Gemüse ist sondern ein upst das
einzige einjährige Obst bzw eigentlich
sind die gar nicht einjährig man kann
die sogar auch mehrjährig haben wer hat
erraten das ist die Physalis also die
meisten Leute bauen Physalis ja
einjährig an aber man kann sie eben auch
im Winter überwintern im Haus und dann
nächstes Jahr wieder rauspflanzen oder
rausstellen wenn sie im Topf ist wir
haben ja auf unseren saltgutütchen immer
auch drin stehen wie tief die unter die
Erde müssen das sind hier 0,5 cm also
mache ich ein ganz bisschen Erde aus dem
Töpfchen weg ich nehme jetzt hier
größere
aussatschärchen weil ich hier mehrere
Samen in ein schärchen gebe und dann
pickiere ich die später in einzelne
Schächen so halber Zentimeter Erde
drüber ich feuchte die Erde jetzt hier
mit der Ballbrause an weil das so eine
sanfte Brause ist da werden die Samen
dann nicht weggeschwemmt auf jeden Fall
findet ihr sowohl die Ballbrause als
auch die
aussatschälchen als auch das allermeiste
satatgut dass ich euch hier vorstelle
also auch die konkreten Sorten bei uns
im Shop der Link ist
wurzelwerk-shop.com und den findet ihr
auch in der Videobeschreibung und im
obersten angepinnten Kommentar die
fysale Sorte die ich anbaue heißt schön
Brunner Gold das ist auch so eine
Youtuber Sorte oder viele Garten
Youtuber mögen die ich nehme zum
Beschriften wieeder eisstäbe das hat
sich irgendwie bei uns so bewährt aber
normalerweise sollte man immer mit
Bleistift drauf schreiben ich habe nur
eben beim besten Willen kein Bleistift
gefunden deswegen jetzt der
Kugelschreiber weil Kugelschreiber
verwäscht nach und nach das heißt ich
muss das dann noch nachtragen und als
nächstes sehen wir Krabi aus das ist
eine lilafarbene Sorte die heißt Azur
Star ist auch eine ganz ja
hartschmelzende Sorte die nicht so
holzig wird da wir nicht so viel Krabi
essen werde ich davon nicht so viel
Aussehen der kommt auch ins Gewächshaus
dann für die erste Ernte also fürs
Freiland würde ich mit dem kirabi
vorziehen noch ein ganz bisschen warten
oder wie viel kurabi wollen wir ja nicht
weil ich mag das ja gar nicht okay ja
der bekommt auch wieder eine schöne
Dusche und dann beschrifte ich den noch
damit wir nicht vergessen was denn da
überhaupt wächst als nächstes kommt ein
Lauch in die Erde aber kein Lauch die
man so klassischerweise im Winter erntet
für den wä es jetzt noch ein bisschen zu
früh sondern ein sommerlauch das heißt
das ist eine Sorte die man in den warmen
Monaten ernten kann und wenn man den
jetzt aussät dann hat man richtig frühe
Ernte und die Sorte heißt Hilari ich
streue die jetzt hier so auf und die
bleiben auch tatsächlich in diesem
Töpfchen bis ich sie nach draußen
Pflanze also das hat sich bei lau bei
mir bewährt der muss auf jeden Fall
nicht noch mal pickiert werden ich muss
euch auch mal hier die Illustrationen
zeigen sind so schön oder das ist eine
Chili die heißt der Cayenne davon sehen
wir auch ein paar aus wir haben
eigentlich noch so ein ganzen großen
Topf voll geflochtener getrockneter
Chili GL und ein ganzes Glas voll
deswegen brauchen wir nicht unbedingt
noch so viel aber ein jah ohne Chili
wäre auch ein bisschen schade und bitte
nicht zu nah an die Paprika ja das
stimmt wir hatten schon den Fall dass
Paprika scharf geworden ist wenn die
neben Chili gewachsen ist weil die davon
bestpöt wurde dann kommt ein blumenkuhl
in die Erde den werde ich dann ins
Gewächshaus oder in frühbitkasten setzen
das ist die Sorte Amabile das ist auch
eine Sorte die ich jedes Jahr sehr gerne
sehr früh aussähe für die ersten ernten
und ich finde das auch richtig richtig
toll wenn man das Gewächshaus bevor die
Tomaten reinkommen noch mal richtig
nutzen kann also die Tomaten Pflanz ich
dann zwischen die Kohlköpfe weil die im
Mai noch nicht erntreif sind aber bevor
die Tomaten richtig groß sind und den
Platz brauchen habe ich schon Maline
blumenkohlerernte und das ist ja wohl
richtig cool viele Leute nutzen ja ihr
Gewächshaus nur im Sommer und das ist
sehr schade weil das eigentlich so toll
ist um die Ernte zu verfrühen wir gehen
die eisstäbe aus das ist der allerletzte
von meiner Hunderter Packung aber mein
Sohn holt gerade schiefernchilder
schieferschilder im Garten können auf
jeden Fall schon mal weitermachen das
hier ist eine frühe würsingsorte die
heißt Vorbote 3 das mit dem würsing ist
ein bisschen wie beim Lauch das ist
jetzt auch keine Wintersorte die würde
ich viel später im Jahr erst aussehen
sondern eine die ganz schnell im Sommer
eine frühe Ernte bildet und die werde
ich im Gegensatz zum Blumenkohl nicht im
Gewächshaus Pflanzen sondern direkt im
Freiland also das ist eine Aussat die
wir jetzt schon fürs Freiland machen
können das hier ist ein gelbtäfelchen
das stecke ich auch noch in die Erde
weil man in der Anzucht ja oft Probleme
mit Trauermücken hat vielleicht hattet
ihr das auch schon mal so kleine Fliegen
die um die Pflanzen drum rum schwirren
die schleppt man sich oft mit der
ansuchterde ein die lfen fressen die
Wurzeln an deswegen stecke ich ein
gelbtäfelchen rein da bleiben nämlich
die Männchen dran kleben das ist jetzt
keine krasse Bekämpfungsstrategie aber
so merkt man eben frühzeitig dass man
welche
und wenn ich sehe dass da welche dran
kleben dann kann ich gleich eine matoden
anrühren und die ins Gießwasser geben
und dann tun die ihr übriges die kommen
jetzt unter die anzuchtlampen und dann
hole ich mir ein kleineres Tray mit
kleineren Töpfchen für Pflanzen die
nicht pickiert werden müssen und dann
machen wir gleich mit der Aussaht weiter
jetzt kommt ein Trick den ich von melena
aus meinem Team gelernt habe das hier
ist die
aushebeplatte für diese quickpot Platte
und normalerweise stellt man die Quick
da drauf um dann von unten sozusagen die
Pflanzen hochzuheben und dann kann man
die einzeln rausfriemeln aber man kann
die auch so draufszen und dann ein
bisschen drücken und dann hat man schon
seine aussatlöcher
t wieder was gelernt mir ist gerade
aufgefallen dass es doch gar nicht so
schlau war mit den Löchern weil ich zwei
verschiedene Sorten Basilikum sehen
möchte Basilikum möchte gar nicht so
tief unter die Erde aber deswegen habe
ich hier die beiden rein mal wieder
eingeebnet dass da keine tiefen Löcher
sind und da Streusel ich jetzt die
basilikumsamen drauf das ist einmal ein
großblättriges und einmal ein
mittelgroßblättriges da ist jetzt die
Ballbrause richtig praktisch weil man
damit die Samen nicht so rumschleudert
auf der Erde also die ist ja sehr sanft
zu den Samen basilikum ist so ein
bisschen so eine schnarichnase deswegen
sehe ich das gerne schon sehr früh im
Jahr aus aber z.B für Tomaten ist es im
Januar auf jeden Fall noch zu früh also
selbst die gewächshaustomaten sehe ich
eigentlich erst so Mitte Februar aus so
jetzt müssen wir gucken wie die großen
schieferschilder hier reinpassen Leute
ich bin richtig scharf auf eine erste
Ernte deswegen mache ich jetzt was was
ich selten mache was aber möglich ist
ich sehe jetzt Rote Bete im Haus aus und
die wird dann in den frühbetkasten
wandern
oder ins gewerchshaus s dass wir ganz
früh ernten können weil ich hatte jetzt
ein Jahr quasi kein Garten weil wir im
Sommer umgezogen sind und vorher und
hinterher nicht mehr wirklich was machen
konnten
und deswegen bin ich ich ich bin ein
bisschen ungeduldig ich muss es zugeben
ich weiß dass es funktioniert ich habe
schon öfter gemacht also kommt jetzt
rote Bee in die Erde da habe ich zwei
Lieblingssorten eine ist Tonda die choja
das ist so eine rotweiß geringelte und
robuschka mag ich sehr gerne es gibt
auch walzenförmige aber ich habe jetzt
die robuschka genommen aber nur weil ich
noch kein Saatgut von der Tondera habe
das kommt aber bald da haben wir dann
auch wieder Wurzelwerks Saatgut von und
wir machen weiter mit Zwiebeln ich werde
jetzt Zwiebeln aussähen und die auch ins
frühbild und ins Gewächshaus Pflanzen
weil ja weil man es kann und warum nicht
haben wir früher im Jahr eine erste
Ernte und können auch den Platz im
Gewächshaus und im frühbkasten möglichst
optimal nutzen wir haben übrigens
unseren wurzelberg aussartkalender
fertig also wenn ihr euch den
runterladen wollt dann schaut auch mal
in den obersten angepinten Kommentar
oder auch in die Videobeschreibung da
packe ich euch auf jeden Fall den Link
rein damit ihr euch den runterladen
könnt den könnt ihr entweder ausdrucken
oder einfach auf dem Handy abspeichern
und da stehen ganz viele sinnvolle
aussattermine drin es kostet euch auch
kein Geld also den stellen wir euch
einfach so auf der Website zur Verfügung
also die Zwiebel die wir hier haben ist
die Stuttgarter riesen das ist auch eine
richtig tolle Sorte eine gelbe die sind
sehr groß sind auch sehr gut lagerfähig
und es ist auch eine Sorte die sich bei
uns schon sehr bewährt hat die heißt
riensburger 5 oder Bingo ich weiß nicht
warum manche Sorten zweiamen haben die
kennen bestimmt auch viele von euch die
habe ich schon öfter empfohlen und dann
kommen wir zu einer ste die es schon bei
uns im wurzelwerksortiment gibt das ist
die isikrona eine super schöne
Frühlingszwiebel die kommt jetzt auch in
die Erde wenn ihr die im Freiland
anbauen wollt dann seht die erst im
Februar aus so jetzt haben wir noch eine
Pflanze für die wie die Löcher wieder
wegmachen müssen als nächstes kommt der
Baku in die Erde da bin ich auch sehr
stolz Euch mitteilen zu können dass wir
den bur das ist für alle die es nicht
wissen eine Sorte die ich in quasi jedem
Video gefühlt erwähne weil ich die so
liebe dass wir den jetzt auch bei uns im
Sortiment haben das ist eine Salatsorte
die sehr sehr frosthart ist und die man
den ganzen Winter überernten kann und
Salat ist ein Lichtkeimer deswegen Streu
sie ich die Samen einfach nur auf die
Erde auf und dann drücke ich die an und
feuchte die mit der Ballbrause an und
hier möchte gerade jemand ausgespritzt
werden habe
ich und ihr könnt sogar jetzt draußen im
BE schon die ersten saten machen ich
muss erstmal warten bis meine Bee
überhaupt existieren deswegen kann ich
euch das jetzt nicht zeigen aber wenn
ihr Zuckererbsen nehmt und die jetzt
draußen aussätt und mit einem
winterschutzfließ richtig gut einpackt
dann beden die kleine Triebe und die
sind wahnsinnig süß also man erntet bei
so ganz früh ausgesähten Erbsen nicht
die Erbsen selbst sondern die kleinen
Triebe das nennt man auch peots in
England und die sind echt lecker die
schmecken wie Erbsen und wachsen richtig
schnell also so könnt ihr schon im März
ungefähr die erste Ernte aus eurem
Garten holen wenn ihr die jetzt aussäht
die kann man auch richtig dicht an dicht
sehen weil da eben wirklich nur diese
kleinen Triebe geerntet werden was ihr
jetzt auch Pflanzen könnt sind
Süßkartoffeln ich habe jetzt hier
einfach zwei Süßkartoffeln genommen und
die durchgeschnitten und dann ein
bisschen gewartet bis die Schnittflächen
angetrocknet sind das ist wichtig damit
sich keine feulnis bildet und die stecke
ich jetzt einfach in die Erde dann
treiben aus jeder der Knolle so grüne
Triebe aus die Schneid man ab und stellt
die ins Wasser bis die Wurzeln bilden
dann kann man die in einzelne so 10 x 10
cm große Töpfe Umpflanzen und Mitte Mai
kann man die dann nach draußen Pflanzen
und hat seine eigenen
süßkartoffelpflanzen gezogen bei den
ganzen aussaten im Januar müsst ihr
bedenken dass das wirklich früh im Jahr
ist und die Tage sind eigentlich noch so
kurz dass die Pflanzen an der
Fensterbank oder im Gewächshaus einfach
nicht genug Licht bekommen würden
deswegen packe ich meine Jungpflanzen
jetzt alle unter eine anzuchtlampe die
auf 16 Stunden eingestellt ist so dass
die richtig viel Licht bekommen und da
gibt es noch mehr zu beachten damit
Jungpflanzen schön kräftig und grungen
werden und nicht so garkillig sind
vielleicht kennt ihr das ja von euren
Jungpflanzen dass die so lange Stiele
bekommen und irgendwie blass aussehen
teilweise vielleicht sogar umkippen dann
schaut mal da drüben vorbei weil da
erkläre ich euch was ihr machen müsst
damit richtig schön kräftig und
getrungen und stark werden und ansonsten
geht raus macht die Welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut tschüss